[Music]
Bart
have you finished watching the office I
think I know I think I'm Mike on the
last see our last last season season I
did me [ __ ] up though cuz I went to
the house and they were like just on
season three I come back a week later
and like dog season I another like Oh
happen to this guy why isn't this guy in
there but you watch Nordahl but you push
play and then take it best something so
you go right now oh yeah yeah that's all
for background noise yeah yeah what you
don't do until you watch it three times
through then you have a background
notebook when you have a cater we have a
choice the true I watch all disjointed
it's all [ __ ] up I don't remember what
yeah but the last season it's uh it's
weird it's kind of weird like everything
just it just feels really weird yeah Jim
and Pam like to get it officially at
this point and are they made this is one
that having marriage problems okay so
they're already married at that point
yeah okay yeah kids stuff it's we're
just cuz a writing style became like
it's not so much about that so what made
the office awesome is there that like
who the characters are and their
dynamics against with each other is what
makes it super funny you don't really
need big plot points to make it funny
but now it has to be like huge plot
points where like like a rocket came out
of nowhere or this came out of nowhere
it has to be like these big things and
make the people react to the events
where that was really not what the
office marriage is falling apart and
then to why it's having to get back with
Angela or she loves him and she's so it
became a drama with homeless yeah yeah
just the source of comedy isn't about
like to pay every day minutiae of things
yeah you put the guy that he got more
broad I would say as the seasons
progressed I like the original concept
yeah for sure
and then obviously not having Steve
Carell on steaks like blue
they didn't Will Ferrel replace I did I
stopped one oh that was like for like an
episode yeah the like guest yes to her
yeah okay boss
awesome cameo this carrot character when
he came back all [ __ ] up from the
hospital yeah I love watching the
bloopers cuz I'm like man he's got
such good actors so I have to watch the
bloopers and I started following Rainn
Wilson mm-hmm and I'm like man this guy
is way different than Dwight Schrute
yeah it's like he's just like a regular
normal guy this is the cool guy Egon and
like he's metaphysical yeah he's like
some I forgot we're religion he's in but
like he's in one of those like very like
spiritual type stuff like yeah like and
on the show Kevin he's always like the
guy that's like wow like he's always
like this and then I watched a zoom
conference between went Rainn Wilson and
him and they're just having a normal
last conversation break the magic for
you know I'm like it made me respect him
as an actor that much more because he
was so slap sticky but believable in the
office that it made me feel like that's
we really is in real life but he's
nothing like that in real life that's
how people feel about us if we're
nothing like how we are in camp on
camera no I thought you guys are almost
yeah you're just a little bit more quiet
maybe a little bit in real life in real
life well not you but like when Barton's
like regular mode you like this exactly
like Jay King is Bart yeah when your
business is big just business huh so I'm
a psychopath
yes no like our character stuff but from
JK films days hey that will be like
everybody but uncle change that's
exhausting you know should be like that
all that's people believe that was who
you were yeah I did characters and I was
like I thought they were real like like
like that and they're just dressed up
it's like the accents are real that's
funny yours really like that and I meet
there on my own okay there know how
anti-climate I feel like all the
youtubers I met that are like sane are
normal people you know and you can
obviously tell them that playing part or
whatever they do they're like pretty
similar then you meet the people that
are like the new wave of influencers and
you're like I can't believe these are
real people cuz they're actually like
they're not even turning it on for
camera they are like that for their
super entitled they need to turn it on
outside yeah and they're like super
crazy super like they're doing stupid
stuff and then you have to be super
exaggerated
and it's like the cat they're on no
matter what or if it's off but then like
say someone's like filming like someone
just takes out the phone instead of
playing story then they all go crazy and
then they just stop keeps doing take
talks at the airport they're all like
and then they and they're just all on
their phones yeah
so they [ __ ] get all expressive and
then they cut yeah everyone goes on
their phone why do you ask me about the
office stuff oh well let me ask you
another question before you jump back
into the office yes I'm excited about
space force I am too from the creators
of the office and Steve Carrell yeah
come space for us and I cannot wait for
that show so maybe cuddling writing for
it I don't think so but uh but that's
not the question though Oh question is
if someone asked you to be your lawful
since up their wedding someone said hey
can you be at my wedding both of you
guys oh you're one of it in character
because I love the uncles so much or the
park so much how much is that gonna pay
me I don't know
then I don't know if that's for free
just charity I don't know the sake of
maybe Oh charity like this will got
leukemia nerd I [ __ ] know it's a
wedding a wedding a real wedding but
some people though for make-a-wish
foundation I want to get married before
I die
actually I wouldn't wanna I just don't
want to go to a waiting period but I
might go as a character but say like
because there's a lot of people that
happens to and they're like oh this is a
joke I'm gonna send out this invitation
and then they actually respond well
obviously they're getting a [ __ ] ton of
press for it now true so it's like
they're if you guys got like went viral
because of it because you showed opening
character just - how about this family
imagine the parks going into a wedding
and [ __ ] some [ __ ] up that'd be
[ __ ] awesome depends on the wedding
whatever the Xoom wedding oh [ __ ] no
it's boring no that's way better in
person
I sure hope is that only want to be a
weddings already attended zoom:1 people
are having zoom weddings right now
some major cameos at a particulars ohm
wedding happened and it went viral what
Michael Scott came oh hey have you guys
seen his show Oh shouts to the guy that
plays Jim John Krasinski yeah he had a
guy that plays Jim Jim yeah John
Krasinski he has a news channel to do
great I see some good news some good
news was doing this like during
quarantine where he talks about good
news in the world that's dope really
anti regular news yeah yeah and he's
just really like down-to-earth and
low-key but is I really like him I don't
even know where to go huh oh that's a
lie I do and guys there's only one way
out of this wedding and Susan and John
like a family elegantly ripped up
Grandma and Grandpa's old I feel like
it's only fitting that you rip off the
wedding too so they did an office
proposal in an office yeah
lady so unless you later the party
ladies and gentlemen the cast of the
office and they're all doing their dance
moves from the Rumba Dean and Pam's
wedding yeah yeah hey here's a nice
house I know I bet they all do the whole
cast my whole cast and most of them came
back for this they committed to the
characters too
yeah that garlic that's time
right Kevin Crede
I like creep easier she doesn't look so
mean no is this music copyrighted do it
to worry about this it's probably gonna
catch it I've seen Angela walk you're on
my friends neighborhood all the time
we're here in LA I can't say bleep
Angela yeah really
oh it's light in person yeah have you
ever listened to their podcast Angela
javis leaving well the biggest
podcasting oh that's great like if
you're an office fan like definitely
check out that bone you just talked
about down-to-earth [ __ ] are they
talking about behind-the-scenes stuff of
the office and all that that's all
awesome what the [ __ ] is going on who
are these people did they get how did
they get invited well apparently I just
gathered Forks I only saw this one clip
but they did the same proposal as as Jim
and Pam at the the gas station yeah
they're they're fans of the show and
then they wrote in or they goof right I
don't know but somehow he found out and
then yeah what happens a lot of times is
that there would just be general good
news that's gonna like that goes viral
and then he'll reach out and contact
those people to bring them on this show
that's all cool it was like what was
that that one the first episode had the
one girl who she was discharged from the
what's little hospitals for people have
cancer oh but she basically finished
four treatments for cancer wards uh sure
no kuznia whoa yeah she finished her
treatments but then the problem was that
it happened right when this quarantine
happened so she couldn't like go home
and celebrate with her family or
anything like so but during her drive
home all of her family neighbors were
outside in front of housing
than were cheering and [ __ ] so then they
he brought her on the show and he like
talked to her super down-to-earth and
made me feel good yeah that's all cool
we did it do positive news yeah yeah we
always focus on like the sad news draw
up your on the nose yeah but like it's
the most clicks you don't understand we
try to do positive [ __ ] here I'll check
a news he's been killing it with us some
good news it's been getting like 8
million 10 million views of it that's a
lot you know but he's also like he's
done very famous yeah if the real news
long time I good nobody would care we
need to have the white and Wilson who
would you want to hit up to be a guest
on jacob javits the office kevin like
the real actor or yeah I want to see
Stephen around oh hell yeah we are the
in character or the let's make it more
fun in character oh yeah Kevin Kevin keV
I love Kevin but he might be like a
better like side gyres of that I don't
know why it's my favorite I'll just
cross discuss crimes with Creed also man
I missed I worked on like a production
for his YouTube channel Oh
Rainn Wilson right oh cool yeah so mad
the one day I couldn't come in was day
he came by said oh it's his channel it's
his soldiers great well says mmm I
didn't know that sorry that like years
ago oh he doesn't show up on set every
single day for some probably just
thought it was just like a little show
that they they had on a channel but it
wasn't like he wasn't hosting it or
anything yeah yeah I want pancakes now
mm-hmm Saul ban cakes mmm a little bit
pancake you'll know better myself
mmm I heard that Trader Joe's has now
Luton free whoo Bay pancakes that you
can get but every time I see the line
I'm like [ __ ] you Trader Joe's you're in
traitor
you gotta go early I've seen it early oh
[ __ ] if people line up before the doors
open I'm sure we're all parents I know
but I don't like waiting well you also
can't go too early because I think a lot
of supermarkets from like 7:00 to 8:00
is senior time so that they can get
their own shopping time so it's gotta be
like by 10 10 so 11 Scott pay one of
those seniors to buy yours pancakes for
you they're already doing it there you
go
smart or do you just go in and you act
like a senior get
didn't character yes I got this anyway
Asian dad crazy Asian press agents look
you look do like the old Japanese act
when you're old you're gonna look like
that anyway water butene water but in do
I come in
he passes little buddy reducing
Wolverine yeah from the Silver Surfer is
what about in you are my destiny
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]